willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es noch mal um die ethik der
künstlichen intelligenz und robotik der
letzten sitzung da mache ich oben rechts
und links hatten wir uns auch mit diesem
thema befasst wir hatten uns beliebt was
unter einem maschinen ethik zu verstehen
ist und heute wollen wir uns noch ein
bisschen mehr mit künstlichen neuronalen
netzen befassen das ist eine neue reform
von künstliche intelligenz die gegenüber
der nur symbol verarbeitenden
künstlichen intelligenz noch mehr
ethische probleme auf zu werfen scheint
und zunächst möchte ich noch mal ein
paar problematische position skizzieren
von denen ich jedenfalls glaube dass man
sich abgrenzen muss davon darüber kann
man natürlich auch diskutieren gerne
auch da unten in youtube es gibt so
etwas wie ideologisierung von k
das ist die auffassung dass man nicht
nur glaubt künstliche intelligenz was
auch jetzt immer künstliche
intelligenzen würde die menschliche
intelligenz übertreffen das ist auch
diese these der starken künstliche
intelligenz im gegensatz zu schwachen
kamen starke k s auch manchmal generelle
ki die bild deutet das
auf ganz verschiedenen feldern
probleme lösen kann und vielleicht sogar
auch
selbstbewusstsein erlangt mentale
eigenschaften gewinnt und dass das nicht
nur der fall ist deskriptive normativ
dass das auch gut ist dass es so sein
soll und dass die menschliche evolution
dort hinführen soll oder führt in einer
sehr positiven weise dass es hat julia
wieder rümelin ein philosoph aus münchen
die silicon valley ideologie genannt wir
kommen nur auf dieses thema des
transform an ismus zu sprechen das ist
also eine transferunion ist ische
auffassung die in meinen augen aber ko
überlegt die zu viel hinein
interpretiert dann gibt es auch dass es
damit auch ein verbunden die
anthroposophie sierung von kali
anderem office muss bedeutet dass man
andere dinge
und wir auch andere lebewesen immer am
eigenen maß nicht nur mist sondern eben
auch so versteht als ob das andere dinge
oder lebewesen ein mensch sei und sowas
passiert natürlich sehr schnell bei
künstliche intelligenz und robotik vor
allem bei republik wenn man dann nicht
nur andere maschinen als menschliche
maschine oder menschliches objekte
vielleicht sogar irgendwann oder
menschenähnliche subjekte auffasste sie
eben auch so konstruiert also wir
scheinen immer mit bezug auf die technik
ganz spezielle mit bezug auf künstliche
intelligenz zur anderem office muss zu
vertreten und ich glaube auch das führt
nicht in die richtige richtung
warum das müssen wir noch diskutieren
dann gibt es natürlich die
entgegengesetzte position die sagt
künstliche intelligenz das ist weder
starke daran kommunismus noch anderer
mensch wir sollten da schön auf dem
boden der tatsachen bleiben und sagen es
ist ein bloßes hilfsmitteln
künstlich intelligenz ist mehr oder
weniger besser taschenrechner und seine
taschenrechner würde doch auch niemand
sagen dass da irgendwie besondere
geistige akte vorzufinden sind etwas
ganz banales input output und
hilfsmittel von seinem alltag es gab es
schon immer hilfsmittel
ist in einem container um zu verstehen
von
bisherigen hilfsmitteln die wir hatten
um unseren alltag zu welten welten ki
ist vielleicht manchmal noch ein
bisschen schneller aber im grossen
ganzen ist es nichts neues das wäre so
die
jetzt nicht mehr das jetzt die
banalisierung these
auch die halte ich für problematisch
weil doch nie in meinen armen zumindest
mehr als ein bloßes hilfsmittel zu sein
schreiben das ist noch ein bisschen mehr
als nur taschenrechner oder ich weiß
nicht was schuhlöffel oder thermostat
thermostat ist zwar auch recht telegent
aber es ist doch ein bisschen mehr warum
darauf muss man zu sprechen kommt und
dann gibt es immer noch die these der
dramatisierung von ki dass man sagt die
ki die wird irgendwann autonom und wird
uns selbst wird wird die macht an sich
reißen dass es so eine ganz starke these
dass wir dann so ein bisschen richtung
und science fiction so
fast schon im inland dramatischen film
charakter über oder dass man zumindest
ganz banal dann auch sagt karin nimmt
uns die arbeitsplätze weg und deswegen
ist
keine große gefahr das ist sicherlich
dennoch philosophisch einleuchten aber
auch mit dieser ansicht dass es eine
gefahr ist kommen wir glaube ich nicht
weiter philosophen schüler sollten
berichten nüchtern bleiben und das setzt
voraus dass wir uns eben ganz klar
darüber bewusst werden was ist
eigentlich ein klick ins und was ist
eigentlich das künstliche von künste
lizenz und über welche intelligenz über
welche reden gehalten wie funktioniert
die und wie ist diese funktionsweise
philosophisch zu verstehen und dazu ist
es ganz wichtig zunächst zwei formen von
kari zu unterscheiden einmal die symbol
verarbeiten de cali und einmal die
neuronale netz struktur oder kollektion
ist ische kamin also die symbol
verarbeitende ki die manipuliert zeichen
und verarbeitet informationen nach
logischen regeln schlüssen gewissermaßen
detektiv all diese regel sind
implementiert diesem system und es gibt
konkrete anwendungsfälle konkrete
situationen da müssen dann lösungen
erarbeitet werden aber der regelsatz
steht fest
und es ist letztendlich so eine
maschinerie die dadurch hat früher waren
schachcomputer so verfasst meines
wissens war deep blue dieses erste große
showprogramm deswegen kasparow gewonnen
hat auch so verfasst auch symbol
verarbeiten großrechner auch der
computer den wir haben ist eine symbol
verarbeitete maschine mit logik gattern
und so weiter sind vor also die
operation sind detektiv logisch
schlüsseln regeln
der vorteil eine die vorteile solcher
sowohl verarbeitender ki ist dass es
recht eindeutig ist was da passiert weil
die regeln nachvollziehbar sind der dude
iwe vorgänge sind immer logisch seckler
nachvollziehbar auch wenn sie natürlich
auf kommt der komplexität für uns nicht
ohne weiteres einzel nachvollziehbar
sind die nachteile ist dass dadurch dass
die regel neben fest sind
dieses system wenig flexibel ist und
recht stark das braucht eben immer die
regeln es kann sich nicht selbst die
regeln beibringen und es kann auch nicht
gut muster erkennen so was damit hat
auch symbol verarbeitende kann die große
probleme und dem gegenüber steht diese
neue tendenz neuer regie so neu ist das
ganze auch nicht mehr
das sind die neuronalen netze das ist
das thema kollektion ismus manchmal sagt
man auch die learning dass es nicht
genau dasselbe
manchmal auch die conversion
kontrolle also das ist dann ein
gefaltetes netze das kann man auch noch
genau differenzieren damit geht er hat
es folgendes auf sich hier wird lernen
nicht mehr detektiv oder intelligenz
nicht mit detektiv getrieben wie bei dem
symbol verarbeitet sondern hier wird
wirklich gelernt auf basis von dem
tierischen daten gewissermaßen induktiv
ist jetzt auch nicht ganz
hundertprozentig induktiv aber hier
ist es ein ganz starkes empirisches
moment da ein beispiel sind ist google
spracherkennung die eben die
spracherkennung basiert auf millionen
von datensätzen die wir selbst auch
beigesteuert haben und autonome
fahrzeuge die eben auch oft mit einer
großen datenbasis von fahrverhalten
basieren hier ist der vorteil dass man
sehr flexibel ist dass das system nicht
so stark ist und das ist system sich
verändert es verbessert sich in der zeit
also es lernt etwas wirklich hinzu dass
es der vor nicht hat mit der zunahme der
operation dieses teams mit neuen daten
die eingespeist werden wird das system
auch besser nachteil ist dass die
ergebnisse die dieses team liefert nur
wahrscheinlich sind es werden nur
wahrscheinlichkeiten ausgegeben während
die sowohl verarbeitende ki immer
eindeutig ergebnisse bringt immer
hundertprozentig gewisse ergebnisse oder
zumindest logisch reduzierte ergebnisse
und hier ist noch ein problem dass
dieser prozess wie zu einem ergebnis
gelangt wird man könnte es auch dem
entscheidungsprozess
dass der nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist
wir kommen gleich darauf erhoben er ist
so komplex so diffus dass wir ihn nicht
mehr wirklich als intelligenz leistung
verstehen können so wie wir es immer
noch bei produktiven systemen wie das
symbol verarbeitung prinzipiell tun
könnten also ganz anderen mechanismus
und neuronale netze wie der name sagt
sind eben dem menschlichen gehirn den
hohen nachempfunden nachgebildet
simulieren das zu einem gewissen grad
natürlich immer nur modellhaft und unter
abwägung von anderen dingen aber es ist
ein angriff anderer ansatz ein vernetzte
ansatz und darauf wollen wir uns jetzt
kurz ein bisschen konzentrieren weil
wenn wir jetzt im folgenden von
künstlicher intelligenz sprechen dann
immer davon symbol verarbeitende ki hat
in meinen augen nicht dieselben
ethischen probleme wie es kollektion ist
ische ki hat warum darauf können wir
auch noch näher zu sprechen kommt das
ist jetzt ein beispiel mit ganz
einfachen neuronalen netzes es gibt hier
eine eingabe schicht das steht hier
jetzt nicht drin das sind die eingaben
drei eingaben das kann alles mögliche
sein was sie eingegeben wird ein muster
eine zahl die wir von hand schreiben und
am ende soll dann dieses netz erkennen
was für eine zahl wir geschrieben haben
also ich schreibe jetzt hier die einst
hingebe die 1 1 die verschiedenen
bildpunkte zum beispiel die durch eine 1
markiert sind auf einem feld und hier
sehen wir schon eine verborgene schicht
dass ein hätten lehrer eine verborgene
schicht die ist eben zwischen eingabe
schon ausgaben sticht das nennt man
alles die verborgenen schichten und hier
alle wird sie sehen alle knotenpunkte an
neuronen sind miteinander vernetzt
verbunden und am ende kommt dann hier
was raus und das system sagt uns dann
mit so einer wahrscheinlichkeit handelt
es sich hierbei um eine einstige
eingegeben so genau so kann man das auch
mit anderen mustern machen man kann hier
ein katzen bild eingeben aber
irgendeinen katzen bild und das system
sagt uns am ende dass eine katze kein
hund es gibt verschiedene arten von
musste man kann genauso gut auch eine
tondateien ton information tondaten
einspeisen und dann sagt uns das system
da diese das ist der satz ich habe
hunger sie können sich das mit allen
möglichen mustern vorstellen die dieses
thema kennen es geht als auch musste
erkennen wenn man hier jetzt mehr als
zwei verborgenen schichten zwischen
eingabe schichten ausgabe nicht drin hat
dann nennt man das die birnen gibt das
ist natürlich eine metapher tief tief
bedeutet einfach nur mindestens zwei
schichten zwischen zu mindestens zwei
verborgenen schichten das wäre jetzt
noch nicht die planung weil es nur eine
verbotene schicht hat es einfach nicht
passt wie katholische bezeichnen jetzt
wollen wir uns noch ein bisschen genauer
anschauen dann hier sehen sie in einem
schiff
die sind diese eingabe seines 74 hand
gezeichnet hier ist eine 2 die wird hier
ein gespeist durch verschiedene
schichten es also die pläne gibt es in
eingaben ausgabe schicht und das ist ein
zweiter lehrer und am ende sehen sie
erkennt das system die sieben richtig
hier die zwei wird gespeist läuft durch
die vernetzung durch und müsste jetzt
hier dann erkannt werden also
funktioniert das system das die eingabe
hin und das hier ist die ausgabe die
ausgabe geschichte diese ganz feinen
linien hier zeigen einfach die
vernetzung an das ist ja unglaublich
dichte vernetzung
ein so läuft das system ab es wird
dadurch gegeben durch das systemen am
ende kommt dabei raus und das system ist
eben nicht jetzt irgendein system sind
das system ist eingespieltes system ist
so verfasst dass die verschiedenen
knotenpunkten nicht gleichermaßen
miteinander vernetzt sind sondern dass
die knotenpunkte gewichtungen haben also
bestimmte
erwäge die dieses diese diese zahl geht
die sind stärker gewiss sind schwächer
ausgeprägt wie auch unsere in verbindung
nicht immer gleich um es geprägt sind
und so müssen sich das vorstellen dass
diese gewichtung wie diese neuronen
diese punkte hier einander verbunden
sind dass diese gewichtungen die können
geändert werden die neuronen selbst kann
nicht mehr geben die sind fest drin im
system aber bei diesen euro miteinander
verbunden sind wie stark die information
weitergeleitet wird das kann dann das
system noch ändern und diese sowie ein
gewichtungen die speichern jetzt endlich
das wissen das wissen dass dieses system
hat das befindet sich in diesen stärken
oder schwächeren verbindungen der
einzelnen holen und eine voll
verknüpftes und gewichte das system zum
beispiel der zeichen erkennen wäre eben
ein solches das hier ganz viele
millionen male zeichen eingespeist
wurden es wurde trainiert wenn hinten
was falsches rauskam eines zeigen
falsche kampf wurde wurde es wieder
zurückgegeben der fehler nach vorne und
so wurde das thema wieder ein bild
trainiert bis diese gewichtungen so gut
sagen dass es alle zahlen die man per
handschrift geschrieben hatte sehr
zuverlässig erkennen diese gewichtungen
und ihre veränderung nennt man eben auch
dass das training also trainiert werden
die gewichtung als die art und weise wie
diese neuronen miteinander verbunden
sind und hier sehen sie jetzt ein
training hier wird jetzt packt aber was
eingegeben von links nach rechts wenn
sie sehen von rechts nach links geht es
jetzt wieder zurück und das das rück die
rückwärtsbewegung nennt beim bag
propagieren dass die fehler rückführung
also wenn eine eine zb 0 1 gegeben wird
und hier hinten aber nicht die null
erkannt wird dann wird dieser fehler den
man erkannt hat wieder zurückgegeben ein
anfang ist dieser fehler maximal also
minimiert wird dass der verein und
patienten abstiegs verfahren nennt man
das einfach geht darum diesen fehler so
gering zu halten wie nur möglich das ist
dieses training dieses netzes verändert
werden nicht diese neuronen hier sondern
nur die gewichtung wie mit welcher weise
diese wohl wieder stärker sie verbunden
sind und das kann man natürlich
millionenfach machen wenn sie sich da
ganz viele geschichten dahinter
vorstellen dann haben sie ganz viele
verknüpfungen ganz viele optionen und
kann man sich schon vorstellen dass wenn
wir das häufig genug macht das dann das
system ziemlich austariert so muss man
sich das wirft uns ein gut eingespieltes
system das einfach für alle möglichen
zahlen am ende die besten ergebnisse
bringt was eben mit der zeit je häufiger
man es trainiert wie man noch besser und
das ist eben das faszinierende an
künstlichen neuronalen netzen dass sie
eben trainiert werden können das nennt
man auch einen lerneffekt
ja so sieht das ganze aus und das sind
diese phänomene die uns eben besonders
interessieren und jetzt kann man sich
fragen was ist unter intelligenz zu
verstehen das haben wir uns auch einen
letzten folge schon gestellt diese frage
inwiefern wird kalli unterschätzt
liefern wird sie überschätzt das hängt
natürlich ganz entschieden damit
zusammen und liefern ki intelligent ist
es gibt ja ein neues buch yorks hot
handbook of fixed a
das kann hier auch sehr empfehlen und
jetzt sagt hier diese autor der kamera
pages männer bisher fischen primarily
due to the transformations nature of
health and science engineering and
junichi also die traditionellen
versuche uns die kg zu verschieben
vorzustellen zu verstehen die reichen
nicht aus hierzu vor 11 6 11 anders dort
kräftig konzept des agency
responsibility intentions ort anime
virtual race der des parents and
interest aller models crowe almost
exclusively
gesagt dass und firmen cognitive ability
riesen behavior es ist es elf pleiten
cording gibt es dieses konzept schon
tools enthält jetzt sagte also diese
bisherigen versuche herkömmliche
konzepte unsere ep anzuwenden auf diese
neuen phänomene die greifen nämlich zu
kurz aber die fische und elegance bild
challenge alt los concepts and more es
beginnt just the bottom of continued
unix systems with that impresses empire
intelligence des ensembles challenge the
way in which we have tried to the basics
vor mylene ja dieses korrekt mobiler
purchase wird die needed to trust die fx
of the future hier stellt die frage
reichen unsere bisherigen ethischen
begriffe aus wie hier jetzt genannt wird
also
handeln agency verantwortung intention
ökonomie
jugendrecht moralischen status bild die
vorzüge belieben und interessen reichen
die aus um sie auf diese neuen formen
anzuwenden oder braucht man nicht eine
ganz neue ethik der kann es die das die
entscheidende frage es gibt eben zwei
positionen die einen sagen nein die
bisherigen ansätze reichen völlig aus es
handelt sich praktisch nur meine technik
tätig der bereich tätig und andere sagen
bis hier reichen nicht aus wir brauchen
ganz neue begriffe wir haben es hier
vielleicht sogar mit neuen form fünf
teams zu tun
ganz wichtige fragen wir werden sehen
dass eben künstliche intelligenz wie
auch die digitalisierung konzept nicht
immer mehr teil unserer lebenswelt wird
also wir werden sehen dass in allen
möglichen geräten die wir haben
vielleicht sogar auch irgendwann in die
plantagen künstliche intelligenz eine
rolle spielen
jetzt sagt dieser auto dieses aufsatzes
challenges die herausforderung vor inter
fünf major crimes erstens konzepte
mbit/s zweitens die erste bis dritte
implementing machine fx viertes tennis
auf scientific expedition im fünften
position versys termin fix coaches wir
wollen uns jetzt hier vor allem mit dem
ersten befassen das betrifft uns als
philosophin und philosophen am meisten
nämlich konzeptuelle begriffliche
zweideutigkeit oder probleme die sich
uns stellen wir als philosophin und
philosophen können vielleicht jetzt
nicht unbedingt diese ganze technik hier
in jedem detail nachvollziehen und
verstehen das müssen wir auch nicht im
letzten detail wir müssen sicherlich
wenn wir der reparierten verstünden
neuronales netz funktioniert uns kommt
es dann aber vor antwort an die
richtigen begriffe dafür zu verwenden
also wenn jemand sagt das ist ein
autonomes system dann müssen wir uns
fragen inwiefern ist es denn jetzt
autonom einfach nur so autonom das kann
es gar nicht sein oder wenn es das wäre
dann müsste es aber auch dass und das
tun so können wir eben darüber reden und
wie immer hängt von diesen begriffen
auch ab wie wir dieses system dann
bewerten wenn es wirklich intelligent
ist wenn es wirklich autonomes müssen
das natürlich anders bewerten als wenn
es nicht wirklich nur einem
eingeschränkten sind autonom ist
ja jetzt sagt das auto weiter leders
kann set up to produce teams in befährt
intelligent agent ein totales agent
taking into account world we have said
erbaute philosophie kommen wenings auf
die streams days to remember the famous
lichtenberg nicht ins bergs messer mit
flexibler tante helga zins die
abonnements agency nama
agence vor dem filmset in drei kreisen
intelligence agency ada intelligence
agency handelt es sich dabei um ein
lichtenbergs messer das keine klinge und
kein griff hat als er sagt praktisch
auch ein künstliches eine künstliches
neuronales netz als autonomen akteur
akteure zu bezeichnen wäre ja ein
doppelter widerspruch erstens weder
intelligent noch ein akteur genauso ist
es weder autonom noch ein akteur
ist es wirklich so oder findet er nicht
noch ein bisschen mehr statt wie es
scheint auch schon die intuition zu
haben dass autonome fahrzeuge doch
irgendwie wenn wir nichts mehr machen
müssen und beziehungs die entscheidung
abnehmen doch irgendwas tun und
irgendwie doch auch handeln vielleicht
sogar oder autonom sind
bei der
sbb topcase ist groß denn
das will reflektiert virtual matrix
bei wurzen post on it and with the flag
er unterscheidet jetzt hier zwischen
einem autonomen wesen und einem
automatischen wesen und einem
automatischen system
automatisch bedeutet einfach dass die
regeln diesem system ja aufgezwängt sind
habe das wäre zum beispiel symbol
verarbeiten de cali diesen automaten
ohne reflexion der eigentliche begriff
von autonomie besagt jedenfalls wenn man
ihm wirklich streng versteht wie er von
rousseau der fall markant auch kommt
dass dieses system wenn es wirklich
autonom wäre seine eigenen regeln sich
setzen würde und sie selbst reflektieren
das bedeutet wir selbst hätten da gar
nichts mehr mit zu sprechen wenn es sich
wirklich um ein autonomes system hat
real für thomas walker redwood shores
bei csu und target das wäre also ein
wirkliches autonomes waffensystems würde
ohne abhängig von uns bestimmen wen es
angriff des jpm leitner hat audi
faszinierend man kompetenz dazu von
military personnel who needs
torsten von appen systems dapd vorliegt
und schon fast im dispo interview mit
ist kleid unlike the military balance
weapons of
it engineering definition sind dies aber
sieht es aus also bin es wirklich
autonom ist einmal ein waffensystem dann
würde dass ich nicht jetzt von
kommandant oder kommandantin zu haken
lassen das würde dann sagen was nicht
bitte in ruhe ich weiß hier schon was
ich zu tun habe und das ist jetzt eine
person und die möchte ich jetzt
angreifen es würde sich dann gar nicht
mehr wir hier sagt kontrollieren lassen
und offensichtlich hat man immer den
eindruck wenn wir mit kari zu tun haben
dann wollen wir es immer noch unter
kontrolle haben und sofern es unsere
kontrolle ist ist es jedenfalls nicht
autonom staaten sind weil es sich nicht
selbst autor selbst und nochmals das
gesetz nicht selbst seine regeln gibt
nach den zahlen sind die regeln werden
von außen gegeben gut so einfach ist es
jetzt aber auch gleich weil wir gesehen
haben neuronale netze können ja selbst
lernen sie können sich ja besser noch
einspielen und irgendwie ja ihre regeln
verändern das sind ja diese vernetzungen
zwischen den neuronen die können ja
immer wieder neu angepasst werden es
hängt also immer davon ab in welchem
kontext befindet sich dieses system und
es ist natürlich immer eingebettet in
bestimmte zwecke im ziele die von uns
diesem system gegeben werden also
erkenne jetzt bitte diese katze erkenne
bittet die 1 und dann erkennt das system
uns aber diese einst die es erkennen
soll die geben wir dem system vor das
system würde nicht von sich selbst
aussagen jetzt erkenne ich mal irgendwie
ich weiß nicht ob es sich dabei um eine
schokoladentafel hand geht oder um eine
chips packung dass das interessierte
system nicht das system ist interessiert
könnte man sagen wir müssen die im
system selbst die interessen vorgeben
und erst dann handelt es sozusagen also
das ist eine autonomie die nur
hypothetisch ist nur unter der bedingung
dass wir dieses system etwas geben wird
es dann aktiv dann wie findest jetzt
klar intelligent kann die intelligente
auch hierzu sagte autogas dies kalt ist
des nero intelligence and the technical
konzeptes taken on am minigolf public
imagination und marc delitzscher
aufsammelt kampagne erlangen wird das
signal wissens der includes a mixture of
world passiert ist world councils
reflexion ihren
exklusiven viel emotion und
fortschrittliche discussion verbaut
intelligence software systems ab auf und
bat mixa pop ja vieles oft kennzahlen
technik ganz in schwarz
also intelligenz wird häufig auch
irgendwie dann vermischt mit anderen
vermögen das ist ganz wichtig kaputt ist
den willen bewusstsein reflexion und
auch sogar emotionen die man dieses
system war ganz in sich an dieses buch
von kathrin wissen
dass wir den letzten sitzung auch
behandelt haben das erneuerer zwei
maschinen ethik das eben auch maschinen
selbst mit ethischen modulen
ausgestattet werden soll und vielleicht
selbst auch mal sensorische
vermögen haben sollen es stellt sich
natürlich immer die frage handelt es
sich dabei um ein wirkliches empfinden
von emotion oder sind diese muster nicht
einfach auch um ganz abstrakt ein
gelernt weil natürlich auch emotionen
muss das sind wir können systeme kannst
nicht in der roman setzt sie auf alle
möglichen muster emotionale muster
finanziellen musste
geschmacksmuster und so weiter
trainieren aber als das dass das system
diese musste auch wirklich erkennt
sprich emotionen fühlt das ist die
spannende frage
und hier wird zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass diese rede von
intelligent immer häufig eine mischung
bedeutet also hier werden populäre
alltäglich ansichten mit philosophischen
und mit wissenschaftlichen ansicht
vermischt natürlich spricht die
naturwissenschaft der häufig von
intelligenz wo irgendwie eine leistung
erzielt wird während wir philosophen
philosophen da wir vorsichtig sind und
ja die gesellschaft vielleicht auch eher
dazu neigt das als intelligent zu nennen
weil es wohl hilfreich ist also hier
vermischen sich einfach verschiedene
diskurse taken into account rückwärts
zettel baute filtersoftware minimax die
streams sind uri sample des filmes
lichtenberg mal wieder dieses
lichtenberg schälmesser since die
abonnements agence am marathon als ein
agent for the philosophy and price
intelligence agency cia agent das eben
nochmal dieses problem das lichten
päckchen messers ja
hier gibt es jetzt das problem das wir
ki unterschätzen aber auch überschätzen
erstmal jetzt hier die übersetzung von
karparti ddr von menschenbabys also die
zweideutigkeiten bezüglich akteur und
intelligenz eine party trug and social
demand driven by cortina media wird over
the dangers fbi ist die menschen auf dem
rückweg
vom boden excess return
of the onset of excess als eine
betreibung der fusion dangers include
but are sd ist operator ende juni
control
kanalisation ob die globuli die
parlamente von
end-to-end das wäre eine absolute
autonomie chutney der portier media as
well as some experts herforder in der
confusion over agency und autonomie
machines es in die kette können wir und
mabel kampf fixiert und spekulativ
wissen xr handel ist riesen foxes und
drei wahres chaos
endete mit interviews angelina jolie
problems and application of dc
technologies dieses tolle problem kennen
sie also wenn man jetzt wenn dieses auto
jetzt praktisch nur die wahl hätte
dieses autonome auto entweder eine
person zu töten also es kann ende nach
links und nach rechts also westen es
kann immer geradeaus oder nach links
nehmen mal diesem fall an wenn es
geradeaus führt natürlich dass eine
person die da einfach auf dem weg liegt
wollt wenn es aber links vierter tötet
ist zwei personen soll es jetzt und es
gibt nur diese zwei möglichkeiten soll
es dann geradeaus fahren und nach links
fahren
manche würden sagen dann soll es
geradeaus fahren wenn es nicht anders
geht wo eine person töten anstatt von 2
das sind natürlich immer auch gewisse
künstliche szenarien die ja ein bisschen
helge holz sein scheinen auf der anderen
seite müsste man schon ein system auch
so mit trainieren dass es in solchen
fällen dann den geringsten schaden
anrichtet wie verhält es sich jetzt hier
in solchen
situationen die gibt es natürlich nicht
jetzt zeit kann jeder sagen diese
probleme gibt schon viel länger
und das sage auf die fischen ziel der
us-präsident will ein anderes thema also
er sagt diese risse risiken links hier
dass da eine eine
aggressive ki entsteht oder in diese
tolle probleme das sind ihr so
überschätzen das ist nicht so ganz
adäquat aber es gibt eben auch noch
beale aber unterstützt risiken for
instance musicale technics die pics of
where cid es fake jugendpornografie
videos der kampagne 2010
an der priorität video von bary der
dispozins zu duos ell vingst chichi
neverdead anna der oper luft
applications bekannt kam es in facebook
ist schon der welt kommentiert
techniques and have been implemented in
china tgv reputations corp das ist ein
automatically denn details meiner laune
fitschen special teams für uns crossing
the green light at the gates of the same
procedure as entities sexual orientation
consumer tenzin and will be subject to
itunes als in china gibt es wohl schon
und systemen die bürgerinnen und bürger
völlig überwacht werden und wo ihr
verhalten von kali
mustern bewertet wird ja also sollen wir
selbst wir frei gewesen sollen mit zu
bloßen objekten der datenbasis eines
neuronalen netzes wert und dann hier
dieses lied fähig ist kennen sie
sicherlich beispiele es gibt die
möglichkeit dass man wirklich jetzt
dran personen dinge dann unterstellt in
einem video zum beispiel die dann so
täuschend echt sind das als ob diese
person diese diäten oder sagen würden
das gibt es auch häufig dass man diesen
personen mundbewegungen antrainiert
durch künstliche neuronale netze so dass
man praktisch täuschung und original
nicht mehr voneinander trennen kann und
hier ja es gibt eine ganz neue form von
darstellung und zwar selbst und auch von
schein der durch cani erzeugt das ist
ein riesenproblem solche dinge würde ich
ihm zustimmen also diese linken dinge
auf der linken seite zählt auch ein
bisschen spekulativ ihr rechts die ganz
banale dinge die scheinen wirklich ein
problem zeigt diese technologie bringt
probleme mit dass man gar nicht mehr
forschung von original und bescheiden
kam irgendwann weil dieses systems so
komplex eintrainiert es bewegungen oder
sonstige sprache musste perfect night zu
erlernen kann
ja das ist die frage die sich hier
stellt also unterschätzen der cani
überschätzen wir keine wo es überhaupt
die zukunft von cali welche bedeutung
sollte ki auch lebensweltlich haben das
war auch nicht frage die in der letzten
sitzung aufgeworfen hatten ist karin
akteur ist kein system eine maschine
oder ist km prozess oder hilfsmitteln
was ist eigentlich da machen sich jetzt
die naturwissenschaftlerin oder die
technikerinnen techniker informatikerin
informatiker nicht so viel gedanken und
diesen status hauptsache das
funktioniert wir philosophin und
philosophen müssen hier ansetzen
begrifflich erstmal hier für klärung
sorgen bevor wir dann zu einer ethischen
bewertung übergehen ja vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit